Delta which is the option Greeks it is
very important of the Greeks
Delta is a relief Tita
etc. What we talk about
Delta which tells that on every one
rupee move in the underline this
how much our option price
[music]  ] [
music]
hello hello hello friends I am your
friend Vivek Bajaj the founder of socket and land
market and crater India's biggest
finance port cast face to face
friends I am very happy to
talk to you again in another friday  I do
n't know how you get excited every
week, when I come to the session, how do you enjoy it,
I feel like every
Friday at 5:00 a movie is releasing
and the excitement tickles the nervousness.  Everything
happens inside me because the
fashion of giving something to you, the love, the passion,
it has been going on inside me for so long.
I have to keep doing this till the time it
is there, so I have
brought another common man of today, who is doing very
less normal now, then it is
not just a strategy sharing platform,
it is an inspiration-taking
platform for common people.  This is the story of
those who have never been done by the big mainstream TV
but we are doing it because we
want you to meet all those who are actually
working in the market
and make money and inspire you, those who are connected with us today
Sailor Sailor Sailor Sailor Understood the one who
roams all over the world in a ship, so he
remained a sailor for 25 years and
at the age of 45 he announced his retirement
and since then he is engaged in full time trade
and Indian from trading.  He did not
do marketing, he started his journey by
trading in global market and now he is
also trading in Indian market and what if I
forcefully
make boring but very effective videos,
so let's invite you, who has been a
seller and is doing very good trading.
Hello  Hello how are you Sir ji
Namaskar Vivek ji Namaskar Gave
us a chance that we can take your story from you
and if we can reach many of my leaders
then I will not take much time
alert between you and our learners
jo state haran tu u aapka
Tell background in little more detail and how you have
converted your trading journey into a good product money making journey.
Tell me, then after that we will go to PPT
Orissa Presently, I am living in Mumbai now, I
was in Orissa till 12th, after that I am roaming outside,
I have done professional course in Bengaluru, then
after that child has also joined, so
be ready  You
then we upgraded it after 45 years
then I and after that 25 years
reduced the ship in many ways then the
merchant also reduced it I was
not getting any solution on 45 around 2016 I
once our ship
I went there
Trained and I liked very much then from
where after signing up I went
to Singapore with my own money then I
also did their tree course and then I
started trading from there ok sir then whenever
I because I March  I also belong to this
and
in our entire family, no one in our family has
any financial background, let alone
any business, so initially I had
a lot of trouble to learn the very
difficult task of financial market from ITO to
I slowly.  Started learning slowly
News paper
last
[music]
When I started my journey I first
learned option a corporate from him so
my trading journey also started
from that market and I
opened trading account in that market and it's very simple
process  Tha opening a threading account over there
and in a way that market when I was trading I
traded for five years but that is
enough for me I would say it's
like n trader's paradise on me
ok because there sir
streets all  According to the monthly
calendar
dollar exchange rate of different types of streets, there were
many other very good
features, which are
not seen in our market even today, like
Multilake Trade
Scholar, Combo Price OK, nowadays they
give and also charge.  Let's do but this about
two wickets ago there yes this and and like
training topless and this about you
can set up for 3 months training stop and
vacation from wherever this kind of features
were very good and went very well like this  It did
n't matter again but I didn't get that time suit to go
ahead because Jagan
Rahat was there again at night and then in suit then I did that
trading band there slowly then
in the middle then in the
international E
yes test in E market I got 20  se nar hi tha when i cute i waise nri good ok
maybe but
i used to have trouble woh me bolna ho
aapko abhi doosra cheez kya hoga
market kar raha tha me woh ki so short hai
because it was 20 faraz market
and whenever i was soni  The market used to go
here and there, then there was a problem, then
I banded e-trading also, let the Indian
market have a
little liquidity,
so I opened it again in the Indian market, but
I was reducing the time in the ship itself.
So in my ship, did you
go in my ship for the third time, only one third
time used to happen at home, then the trading was not so good, I did
not know that much, then there was
also the issue of internet connectivity, then those problems
were there, but still all these problems
Despite this, I did my learning,
I kept doing continuous learning,
hoping that in the future, those people who will get
me to do it, then I will be
happy to see how my trading performance is
happening, from
2012 to 2016
but and after leaving again  When I
stayed at home for 24 hours, then that time also actually speaking,
I used to do part time business like full time trade, because
I used to do some other activities also, so
I did not know how to do full time for that,
so I did part time business.  When there was no time, then
how did I become a fool of the time trade? This is because of
comedy. Letter
never got lost.
I used to roam a lot before I could withdraw it, then it all got
banned, whenever I became a full time trade,
then the profits started coming more and started getting
better, then
I used to train the time and even today  I
train in it, I do many types of
status, which I do, mostly it is
not a complicated strategy, if it is not a
simple strategy, it is my relief, like
star strong, iron condom and butterfly,
when to do it, it depends
on the fix, what is the technical Internet slow?  hai
data kya bolna hai ok and by the way
in intraday
we do when this
star etc. now my target is rahat 15
to 25 point hai most in d bank
ghat ghat water piya piya after that you
got the courage that now you are in this sea  So
let's take your PPT and
discuss with you from there friends very
interesting discussion is going to happen because
Sharad Bhai Jo hai woh bata do it
yourself Karmath Yogi ji
says that by doing himself he taught
multiple  They have
come to India with exposure to the market, it is not that they
started directly in India, so now their wisdom is enough
and I have seen that I have a friend who has
also been a seller.  If
working is so requested
then there is a lot to learn plus
he is a yogi teacher so today very interesting
discussion is going to happen guys little time will
not work I will try for one hour so
you have little time but we will get
a lot in this so please fox  Will do and
start as much as possible
that ever since I have done yoga, my entire
Streets, my
style of trading has become completely clouded and I am
profitable, so far as my success is concerned,
in this trading career for
more than a decade.  I am doing this to a large
extent, this is what Yogi Practices,
which I do,
Sir I have trading strategies, which is, I have to
keep some strategic 15 to 25 points
and like if two or three times profit
comes from expiry
then  Sir my favorite
I do a lot depends on the
situation like I said it
is a relief and in a lot of situation we can do this by
adjusting which we
can either take a small loss here in the net if there is
not a big profit then this  That's why
this is my favorite street Rahat and this
street which is small can be done even in small capital,
if there is 2 lakh capital, then it is
very good street, so we will
see it in extra, let's first understand its basic rule.
I buy 50 delta and
sell 35 delta,
then
in ball debit, which should be more de
loss percentage Sharad bhai, there is one thing that this
is delta, once
explain it in easy language, 50 delta and 35  Delta
means what happened and if you want, you
can also show some of the extra blood,
which option is Greeks, it is very important of Greeks,
Delta is a relief, θ is wet, if
we talk about it,
it tells what Delta is.  hai ki aur evry one rupi move in
d underline hai
means agar
50 paisa
to aisa isse understanding hai in simple language so
this is not our hard and fast rule
that 50 delta should be delta
dharma
they can discuss this and they can  c it is
best
ok dost hai hum after taking the trade that
ours also went right and trade conduct either
our trade went wrong then both have the
specialty that adjustment is necessary in both situations
so we are ok where ever we are
yes  One thing whenever we go view right
and do adjustment then our
adjustment then
margin retirement gets flooded ok
whenever we initiate this trade
debit spread it
goes something around 22-25000 and then adjustment whenever  If we
adjust our view right,
then our margin does not increase, so
we have written max 30000 here, even
within
30000, our margin does
not increase, our retirement
does not increase, whenever our flood is called,
but whenever our  We will adjust only then
our margin retirement will be flooded
yes then we should do dead lakh with margin of one lot ok we
can put 10 thousand like this for
2 lakh but don't do this if it
is 2 lakh then one lot
Because we must have some capital for
adjustment.
Whenever we take a train, we have to first
walk thinking that our train may be wrong
and whenever it is wrong, we
must make adjustments, then we
How can they either make a small loss or make a small
profit, so let's need an
addition margin, whenever there is a
loss, ok, whenever
we are, first we will take an example in which the
trade is our color.  Ok
we will take train then we will take food side and
debit side we will
start whichever goes then whenever
sale like premium becomes half whatever
premium will remain salary premium will be
halved only then we will start adjustment
Ok so whenever we do
before we start we have to
see where is the support
resistance because after
making adjustments it does not turn upside down, by
making adjustments you are making it risk free
but then you move upside down too.  Can and
then your adjustment even then
before adjustment you have to do by looking at support
resistance or drawing some line of your price area
etc. ok then
ok then this is what whenever we
start adjustment we told that  When it becomes half the
lovers in the cell only then
we have to start the adjustment, what do we do at that time, we do another
cell, which is 35 delta back
delta,
we do another cell;
1.3 to 1.5 then 1.5 lakh
margin is required at least
if
reversal is expected then we
can make salary
so we will see after going ok ok let's
do right
and as we can see here
3030 is going ahead in minutes it
just started from here it will be
50% premium then we
will shift so now 162 was our entry price
so it is around 81 so we will not get 81 let's
look back and forth
so this  76.5 ours will
start
but 35 delta is to see if that 43000 which
we have drank is not the same then if it
is then take the one below it
like I said 53000 35 so we
can't do that so we and  29 wala will sell
a little let's highlight it
so see what is going on now
if our market goes up then
our loss is not at all 6.2
ok so this is our but you
see delta
around 15 positive
so sir we second adjustment
[music]
because we have to adjust it out
okay so it's in it we have to adjust it out
now we've gone back there
if we think we can go to the charts now and see
we have 15 and five's 28
so they  R har
[music]
See we are seeing a resistance so
whenever the next date will open the resistance
if not here if the
resistance goes down if the recent
record is not done then we
must be ready for an adjustment again like  If it comes, it is
not visible at the moment, now it is singing mother's
police, so we
[music]
one police will see it someday,
if there is a reversal, then what to do
sir, this adjustment is like we have
spread the fibers like now
Now this is basically, we have made an
adjustment here and there, by
spreading a debit, there is nothing, it has become a research position,
as if the market comes slowly, then we will
get that profit, then they
put it again,
sir here.  But the market was
going, then it started getting reversal, so
if it is coming slowly, then there is no issue,
it will decrease gradually, it will do so while going,
if it goes here and there, it gives us profit and
goes away, but the problem arises when it goes
fast.  If it comes down then we will
see another one for next week.
Me to aadmi
dekhne toh bhi banna raha hai bhi see bhi hai
support is almost here [
music]
here the market is opening let us
make a view
whenever we want to take a trade then we have taken such a
random example
so it can be reverse so that is why we have to do it
We will discuss with more adjustments
then this view is going right so this view is
ours that market will go up then we
should take 10 15 now we are starting 926
so here we have just put a line
of resistance then there  When it comes,
what will we do with that
point, we have to
see, because we should
kill it,
as it was
our view that the market will go up, so
we have taken tomorrow, so now we
simulate it and see
when we  Also market go in our fever
go according to our view
we start adjustment even then
atlist when we make 50% again
not before that 700 800 point or 1000
max profit
then we start in around 2000 level
We will adjust it ok, it is
very simple to adjust this
file leg, we have to close it and
we have to sit on top of it, like we have a gap in it, there
is a gap of about 300 points, so we
can come up to 43100, so this is  Let's try this
then they close now
and we will close at 43000
but age max jen has also reduced a bit
now 4000 see now it has gone to 3900
so
our dr side is still showing little loss
we also zero loss  Can do if
we take a little more highest frock then
we
see 200
basically the one which is 50 delta and 35 delta
which is your thot you will always
maintain that
total
now 4300 one more we will sell
for 3000300
Agar aapko bhi ki market aur
jaan nahi aapki ki mujhe ok [
music]
abhi to aapko top ka chinri itna u can continue
with de trade but
in de se time bhi u can exit de trade with
watter profit of your 50% profit  Your made
already of de maximum profit or you can do
adjustment or remaining date
so ons your trade becomes you can remain
in de trade if you like you full debt
market he de potential to of father
give you can remember in de trade or you  Full
debt market will not go much, here it is about to
expire after roaming around a lot, then
you can convert it into butterfly and here
it is expired, then give it
maximum profit 8000,
something, a little profit, 6-77 and
this  Also they can
adjust make
minimum profit hai isko bhi
sakto hai aur baad jayegi kabhi humne feel na hum
so good profit kariya tha gone [
praise]
over here and 82.7
and we have to come 43 20043
adjustment
should trigger point what
Trigger point as I told sir your
50% profit has gone
and you may have less problem in loss
now see sir we have just
done one by one article i.e. 43000 ₹ 300
gap we have 100 points  Ka gap me abhi water
kiya toh abhi see jo minimum profit hai
woh humara tha hai
jo hamara hai itna mil raha hai before starting this adjustment
2012 [
MUSIC]
Experiment
me kya kaisa tha market tha
to yeh fifth me
[MUSIC]
her  Will take it later
okay
see here the market has turned up ok ok I
want to show live
now see here actually sir
my question is when will we do this trade on
monday now because in the beginning
of the presentation you had said
not you  Experimentate karte
jo
view ka zaroor hai without view they should not initiate
d tray I understood
everyone because I want you show
d adjustment if it goes
well then adjustment will be done
Australia
this is just me showing it not
mean friday start  do aur
thursday to hall karna
par exam jaise yahan pe humne dekha yahan pe
dekhte top ban raha hai
I bill like it ok because yahan pe neech aata hai
phir up gaya market yes but most
likely I bill exit har itself because
main kar tu exit  i am showing this taking
on friday and i am running it just tu
show ho tu adjust d train
34.2
karna hai
76 ok till then
75.5
delta ka bhi showing same to hum aur
nahin lenge
500 ka
see below if market story  Even if we
lose our loss maximum and 45 will
still remain Prajapat Mahavir so
if we hall it because it
is like a fiber spread and if we hall it then
we can come in danger so we
have to save ourselves now so to
save it  What do we do, we will sell food,
why will we sell food, because there
is good support here, and it has gone up from here, and
you have come in and you have come to know about it,
and see here, there is
good support, from here the market is up.
Our adjustment should be triggered if the 15 min candle has gone above
this support
market
so we have to
convert it into star struggle now to
triangulate it the
market has taken your support from there let's
see again
For this we are selling Potato 300 which is
only ₹700 below so so this
way happening is trying to get on the right
side if market mood is getting upset then it
is getting upset
but here you see  It is possible that
we still have more danger in your side, so
this 300 feet we sold is
not adequate, so for that we
should do 42 feet,
then yours will increase and this too will
break and flood. 43 800
9009  Ka upper break one
say
normally
door possibility of making loss and let
they adjusted so tha be come out de loss and
however insad also atlist come out with zero
loss and profit so they bill look tha spinner
you we already in a small profit this  reached it about
one day before yesterday profit they have making
so every
may have
retired his margin in this at
other point time
[music]
global here which support you maybe
start trade here and go up
or here  You are seeing resistance
from here you could have taken India something like
date
but with view only you walk so
most of the time your trade bill according to your view
and bill give you super profit because
whenever profit comes  So at
least
20283000 profit comes, then if
we get a capital of 2 lakh even with a capital of 2 lakh, then
there is a good profit
[music] [
music]
110% oh my god your 223 around 55%
not at all  ek mera one of d
strategic aur yeh mera jo streets maine
batiya saare jo hai
struggle struggle mera mostly trade rahat hai
condom trade etc rahat hai aur position
defense aur it jo depends on d bricks
aur date of flow date is comming in some times
i am  Note in trade some times I get in
trade and get out with in minutes seeing the
opportunity it is only
time relief so if
this strategy is seen then
I have made a view that it is fast then I
will keep doing it day by day view change  If it is done,
then I will start doing the reverse, then
why shouldn't
these be perfect streets?  You are making this
price whatever you are following like
you are doing something like moving average or doing
something like RSI
then you can continue straight it
is very low you can easily adjust it  You can do it
and goes by giving bumper profit
ok but don't have to grid it like
I said if you have two because it
goes to 20-25 thousand margin then it does
n't mean 2 lakhs then you must have taken 10 lots
ok you are dead  1 lakh 2 lakhs have been caught,
take the train according to each lot, if
you have views and you are making a good special
profit and you have refereed,
then the remaining margin is your child, you
can do something else in it.  And by doing some other term
trade, you can extract extra,
but don't put it in starting only,
always just take any trade, then
it should be done with an eye that our view can be wrong
and if it is wrong,
then that eye  If we want to move from this, then there should
be a good margin for that and the
method of adjustment will be less
in the chart or whatever your
method is, it should be done by planning in advance,
then Sharad Bhai I think I have given it in your presentation.
Very important, yes, let's go let's go through
this, many people ask us, but my
friends etc. who are in the machinery, how
can they leave me
?  When will we leave,
how will we leave, we can leave, according to my
own experience,
I have written that it may not be like this in any book, so
mine is such that
if you want to become a full time trade by waiting  The
first thing is that it should be
done with full planning, if you
want to wait for the final, then that much time is
your capital,
say your contingencies form or reserve fund, whatever it is, should it
be yours, should it be in your bank account
or team  Be that as it may, the
normal expenditure of your family for 3 years, which is the
expenditure of the education of the children,
it can run even if your 1 year is negative,
even if you have traded for one year,
still you have not made anything.
Even if you get it, you will be able to sustain it for 3 years, that much
setting should be yours and one more thing, the
most important things are how many people
become that
when they are gone,
this is the reason for
looking, when we are sitting now, let's go a
little  Try kar lete hain trading no
date ise d most time you do
ok so me expense date you should be
trading we should we thinking of wick full
time period of only when you are come de
pick up your carrier and you have enough
note when you are  last your when things like ok mast be very plain d way after
doing
things i
bill b ko on d next slide sir
many people ask me because whenever i
was in merchant navy no marking then
get very good salary
and you are discharged  In the house, your
salary is coming every month at home, the
rest of the negative points are
because of this, except what I have told you, you do
not get family time
and there is no creativity in less, there is relief, you do
not get to do anything differently.
I had to leave soon but
style I left
this reason so you can say that the
most important reason was for me to
remove from Comfort John
because he was very comfortable going
here let's go in the ship and salary remained
every month and  Ya feeling so good about it but once you get
stuck in de cycle you can never cute you can never lead a
normal life hai ki you can not
show higher in your life ok
mera ghar chalna chahiye aur thod bhot
saving hona hona
[music]
To Yeh Tha Computer
[Music]
Express Traders Also Ho To Offer Come
You Greatest Virtue Of Any Successful
Trade Hi Patience Aur Disciple Unless You Are
Patient And Your Discipline Devar Is
No Way You Can Successful That Is Me Personal
Believe Aur Ho Tu Develop
[Music]
and take lot of practice you do
reading in a book or self help book bill not help told
me this but I go in yoga practices but it help me
so I would say date it is one
of the waste where one can generate this what and
I don't  Hav to agar agar par example
as we know that you are bringing debit side like you are,
then you will not take it like you will
first see the chart level before taking it, either you
will see whatever your data point is, then after doing that
After planning, you should know
that at which point you may need to assess,
then
you will have to be ready for that point, when that point comes,
you will have to adjust, then that
planning and trade in advance and once.  Your plain
jo trade stick with it don't cup
change in de plane or tree you over trade de try to increase
de quantity which date you know
so or one think like when we are doing
trading like
specially you have to what I also do
interact hai very  small amount what i do
percentage you will be
tempted again you inter
date kid of word youtube
profit you inter you last date or you last
bar ok mean by this is it when you are trading you
concern on your trading you are new
technical data points what over  But don't be so
match company on tv do switch on
d tv loud volume and cnbc and
blubber what ever and tree you trade and you are
in middle of
some activity
and other
trade method
faithfully actual
scenario me paper trend in actual
scenario me karna hai paper trap  ok only
12 limited extra but i bill recommend do
n real trade with real money main bhi one lot
date fine but do with real money par some time
aur sit off next turn over of date aur
try tu cup your next door dr in single
digital  ok
sum chart
karna hai aisa nahi karna hai
possible tree you make your trading is boring responsible don't make
you make n gan
dumper round and minimum make loss
par exam maja ae gaya
sharad ji
maza ae gaya itna honesty itna simplicity
exactly mean one of your presentation  The thing was
clearly coming that
this one thing was understood from your
presentation that genuine people
you adopt
s shot off word maja e gaya mujhe sir
ye train jaan mein jaan
thank you to many people before i want to do
trading journey  It has been a story, a story, in
one way or the other, many people came
into my life
unknowingly helped me in one way or the other,
but as an example,
I have come to the finance line of trading,
because one of our ships
Engineers are engineers of one who has just
joined the ship, so one day he had
brought the
name of the magazine called Intelligent Investor,
nowadays it is called Outlook Investor
[music]
which I saw and read then I
got interested in it like this  There are many people
who have helped me in one way or the other,
so I
would like to say thank you to all of them and have
not done the seminal seminar, everyone has
seen its free video, I have seen a lot of videos in YouTube etc. I am
relieved, I am also relieved on Facebook.  I have
done video free seminars,
all of them have asked me to learn something,
so I want to say thank you to all those trains and all the
mental ones,
and sir,
I watch your channel regularly.
Traders have come,
successful traders who have done a lot in life, they have got to
learn a lot from them in life, I want to
say thank you to all of them,
so first of all I want to say thank you
and friends, one thing
in your computer  Can you give email id,
nothing is
needed, should not go to anyone else,
WhatsApp id, your butt is good, it is good,
sir, let me touch and gas, please
take as much learning as possible from their videos, I
think very seriously that this video is from India.
Learning has happened and if possible, see once more,
see twice, then actually you will
understand the whole essence of adjustment and essence of trading psychology.
Also ca
n't be complete in one video and there is
a special thing in face to face that we have interacted a lot in
such a way
that people have blessed us
with good content so this method of adjustment is
simple and effective by adopting it  Lene To
Atlist Apna Layer Of Journey Chalu Karna
Thank You
Mumbai Aata Hoon To Meet Hoon Aapse Kabhi
Thank You Thank You [
MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]